lo sa bene visto che si sono nuovamente
qui cazzo detto tra l'altro voglio
capire un secondo come ma tu sai comando
io e la prima volta che apro questo
ciclo qui perfetta quindi non so che
bello funzionano allora ragazzi è una
roba più o meno tipo che mario non lo so
però è da fare in nome quindi ci uccide
scorgiamo come fatto come il fatto vai
vai a ok ok grandissimo no a scusa mi
dimentico che c'è stato ma che ti
dispiace guarda se è come cat mario a un
certo punto dovremmo censurare di 90 per
cento di cui video sì esattamente
madonna il casinò o finisci lo questo
sulla fiducia ai miei ragazzi sanno che
non ce l'avrei fatta
devi dimostrare ai tuoi che sei un pro
player forza poi vedere ora che potremmo
stare qui qualche vi era lo dico ma
perché sono un gatto ma ma dai
finisco livello è normale questa cosa te
lo dico perché sarà così sempre di bassa
[Musica]
di storia
senti così bellissimo
no sono caduto scrivere no bellissima
sta cosa se ti abbassi posso saltarti
soprano sembra una cosa veramente brutta
io non vorrei neanche farlo notare però
si fa qua non puoi farlo a meno che uno
non si suicidi per la aspetta parte
aspetta aspetta guarda guarda guarda mai
è grande
io posso stare qua tutta la vita e lo
sto garantendo allora cai di cascare e
più grande a fossa posto non so come non
lo rifarò mai più
chiamami yoda
no grande yoda grazie prego marzo ma you
the matrix
mamma mia non ho visto sei morto alla
fine allora iniziava a diventare
difficilotto è un parka merda ma come lo
finiamo mettete può tornare indietro si
sa non è possibile non è fisicamente
possibile a come hai fatto e bravura
proprio allo stato puro va bene bravo e
allo stato puro finisci questo ok
mamma mia squadra voglio adesso lo staff
oscar judo a guardare come hai fatto
sopra non è possibile che tu sopravvivi
quando nei giochi dovresti morire cedo
l'onore di andare a destra per primo
grazie caro complimenti aspetta ma come
come come si passa poi mezzo impossibile
che era impossibile
devi spostarti da lì perché se ti prendo
poi bestemmiamo in due io posso faccio
prima che trick ok perfetto madonna
tecniche coppia santo di dio come sei
morto aspetta aspetta aspetta dio
oddio oddio oddio oddio cominciavano mai
più veloce sento proprio l'effetto
catuma non ho sbagliato scusami finora
ce la siamo abbastanza cavata senza
troppe strano è grave cioè tu sei morto
e mi giunse morte
[Musica]
capita capita grazie per facebook o che
casino no io non avevo visto che c'erano
le spine qui c'è proprio qualcuno che ha
visto neanche il punto allora specie ce
la posso fare
vai tranquillo so quanto l'altra cosa so
it begins l'hai presa anche tu la
chimenti è perché siamo abbiamo finito
il primo capitolo quindi questa è la per
dire va bene non siete proprio delle
merde ma inizia adesso devi centrare il
buco sei proprio che noi sappiamo fare
grande cosa stavo uscendo guarda ho
un'idea però devi provarci tu mi aspetta
sei pronto io non ho deciso di saltare
più in alto dai prototipi porca merda ma
non pensavo di prendersi ok grande a
massimo a fare il doppio salto aragon
imbrattato di sangue tutto il livello
sull ex enel doppio saeco perfetto
[Musica]
problemi denudo se ce la fai meno ma
meno male che sei morto no io infatti
già denudato lo volevo anche vedere ad
un sogno erotico di tutti quanti sono
traguardi vai vai avanti tu per me
traguardi della vita stato proprio una
rock che ha mi sparano che figo quindi
io l'ho distraggo e tu vai ti aspetta è
pronto
vai vai a cazzo funzionalmente non
pensavo qua mamma mia che em trinec che
team ci provo ma mi sa che non ci riesco
però ci prova
sì no no no no no no no sì sì sì ok ok
perfetto va benissimo ma sta diventando
pesante la faccenda non so se ecco io
come sia finiti tutti e tre che lo so
dov'è allora aspetta ma dovevamo
giocherà proprio credo o non ci credo
non ci credo
così facendo però quante imbrattata di
sangue sta parte ma è diventata come una
donna in quel periodo del mese grande
giardino come hai buttato all'aria
l'unica possibilità che avevamo di
vincere è brutta
rompi oggetti in casa aiuta il cazzo non
fare qui aiuto sai come hai fatto
no
o no
[Musica]
sì se questa grande cazzo complimenti e
grazie gradirei che ci fermiamo qua
reagan lo sto facendo
cava o aspetta aspetta aspetta a ti puoi
fermare lì non ci pensare perché ti
blocca il cosmo madonna un grande al
posto ti prego vai avanti dai potevo
fare di continuare anche per anni ci
siamo due geni comunque oddio dove sono
da trovare
ora vorrei cubo che c'è un naso che gira
aspetta un attimo che appena spara
un'altra volta bravo hai questi momenti
in cui te ne esci che fai le cose che
non si capisce come adesso tutti gli
spieghi che porta a questo aspetto
aspetta che non so come hai fatto ma
provo anch'io vai vai vai di culo uno
che culo muro all'ennesima potenza va
bene così noi li trovate altri due così
sento una cosa che è viva da sotto
proprio io ci ho fatta siamo tutti con
te fare si guarda ti sia affidata la
persona giusta
matteo detto il re come si è prego puoi
anche di farlo volendo no no no no no no
kat
allora posso ritornare giù no non ci
crea spettano c'è un tasto per andar giù
vado io so se è arrivato il più perfetto
perfetto da fini così bello rimpiangi
settimane è dio cos'è la stessa cosa no
da parte tragica morte o ati grandissimo
io sono morto per il lag ma quanto siamo
due di 8 e tanto e si però lì come
[Musica]
si sa il culo che motori turbo dai dai
dai che ce la fai non lo vedo che che
chi ci sei carico la puoi fare
madonna da applausi altro se vuol dire
network
personali e spregevole di questo pianeta
io ti voglio bene prosegui ti prego
qua c'è un punto dove ci siamo salvati
per mai prima prima le signore guarda un
nobel per il tempismo esiste
ok ok so che questo quando devi fare non
si possa crepe non l'ho capito devi
correre più veloce grande
ok non ho parole no se è caduto nel modo
più tragico della storia perché me lo
dici crisi siamo tutti quasi annusati le
chiappe è un topolino va fermato cosa ho
fatto
oddio no se ti sei affidando a me per un
no non ci posso credere aspetta che
faccia sì sì ok ok ma vai vai vai caro
vai caro mai così non puoi stare a
trovarmi ogni bolla con calma
grazie era doveroso era ormai direi che
possiamo concludere che questo episodio
ragazzi è stato veramente ma veramente
veramente veramente poi capelli dritti
provare a fare questi livelli con il
buon re sen
continuiamo nel prossimo perché
ovviamente lui non vede l'ora di
continuare vero caro solo e uno
suonatissimo da fare questi nuovi perché
non vediamo allora ragazzi di iniziare
però vabbè dai io direi che possiamo
chiudere qua ci vediamo nel prossimo
episodio però credo che sia piaciuto un
mi piace per il buon rex anche o per
ogni mi piace si ripiglia si vede che
già funzionato ma sento si vede più da
superamento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e condivido stata iniziata
senza vestiti scarpe ci vediamo ha
proseguito era ragazzo
[Musica]